quienes llegan a la feria del libro de
Buenos Aires en esta edición número 47
casi inevitablemente tienen que
atravesar este pasillo y aquí se
encuentran con esta muestra fotográfica
organizada por la feria del libro y la
asociación de reporteros gráficos de la
República Argentina que recorre en 40
fotos los 40 años del regreso de la
democracia a Argentina la muestra
comienza con esta imagen de Raúl
alfonsín el primer presidente de este
periodo democrático en el país asumiendo
en 1983 y las imágenes van recorriendo
la historia política económica social
cultural y también deportiva de este
país de hecho las imágenes finales de
2022 son las del triunfo argentino en el
mundial de Qatar decía que es casi
Inevitable atravesar este pasillo porque
para las organizadores uno de los temas
centrales justamente de esta feria del
libro 2023 son los 40 años de la
democracia y por eso le dieron este
lugar privilegiado a esta muestra